عمليه عسكريه مشتركه بعدد كبير من
الصواريخ البالستيه والبحريه والطائرات
المسيره استهدفت سفينه امريكيه كانت تقدم
الدعم للكيان الصهيوني ان العمليه جاءت
كرد اولي على الاعتداء الغادر الذي تعرضت
له قواتنا البحريه من قبل قوات العدو
الامريكي يوم الاحد الثام عش من جماد
الاخره
1445 للهجره ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
تؤكد انها لن تتردد في التعامل المناسب مع
كافه التهديدات المعاديه ضمن حق الدفاع
المشروع عن بلدنا وشعبنا
وامتنا ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره
في منع السفن الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله من الملاحه في
البحرين العربي
والاحمر حتى وقف العدوان ورفع الحصار عن
اخواننا الصامدين في قطاع غزه ان القوات
المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد حرصها الكامل على
استمرار حركه الملاحه في البحرين الاحمر
والعربي الى كافه الوجهات عدا موانئ
فلسطين المحتله صنعاء الثا من جماد الاخره
1400 145 للهجره الموافق للعاشر من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه